[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es mal wieder ein richtig
schnelles und einfaches super leckeres
und gesundes rezept ich werde mit
couscous pfanne mit gemüse machen
ihr könnt sie als ossis vegetarisch ihr
können sie gerne auch vegan zu bereiten
im prinzip habe ich nur am ende so ein
bisschen käse den ich drüber streuen
ansonsten wäre sogar die pfanne komplett
vegan supereinfach und wirklich
innerhalb von nur 15 minuten fertig 15
bis 20 minuten
ich sag euch mal die zutaten ihr könnt
natürlich auch abwandeln und variieren
vor allem mit den gemüsesorten passiert
da habt ob ihr champignons oder
auberginen und was euch schmeckt und was
er da habt und ansonsten legt direkt los
also ich brauche dafür drei esslöffel
olivenöl 1 knoblauchzehe drei zucchini
zwei rote paprika und karotten etwas
gemüsebrühe couscous tomaten eine rote
zwiebel 2 frühlingszwiebeln und
petersilie
hier habe ich noch salz pfeffer und
getrocknete minze und etwas nomaden käse
und hilfst du mir okay
kammer weiter her rasch nur gegessen gut
was kann ich dir geben
zum schneiden kuck mal wer vierteln die
tomaten und zwar nimmst du das machst
aber nicht die hände rein weil das in
bester drin
ok und jetzt kannst du die tomate
reinlegen man warte man erst mal die
ärmel hoch und daumen ding gehört laut
kohl - so bist du ein kleines lämpchen
was petersilie ist die tomate reinlegen
und hier das kommt hier rein und dann
einfach zu drücken
einmal feste jetzt hast du die thematik
geschnitten ohne deine haben zu
schneiden kannst du das alleine
und letzte super gau kommt oder kleine
tomate hast machst es einfach so und
dann kannst du dir auch machen jetzt
normal drücken perfekt vielen dank
dankeschön
dann mache ich hier kurz weiter okay
okay ich kann jetzt zuerst einmal das
olivenöl in einer pfanne erhitzen
denn das geht jetzt direkt schon mit dem
kochen los
nehmt jetzt auch eine schöne große
pfanne wo wirklich auch das gesamte
gericht rein passt dann kann ich die
knoblauchzehen fein hacken
ihr könnt sie auch fein reiben oder
pressen
er liest du hier
mit der ganzen petersilie ist du dir für
mich ja cool
ok hab schon noch etwas übrig gelassen
ja ok
knoblauchzehe kann ich jetzt hier schon
mal anbraten
wollten wir helfen hat die tomaten
geschnitten die petersilie geklaut und
ist wieder gegangen wäre hätte mich
einfach an morath erlebt um zu essen ja
ist echt so ich habe schon ganz viele
videos gemacht in denen ich einfach
gefilmt habe wie er da ist wenn sie ist
da kennt so nix das los geht es hier bei
mittlerer hitze anbraten und kümmere
mich um die zucchini die zucchini wird
jetzt eher grob gewürfelt
ich will nämlich das so schön bissfest
bleibt also erstmal halbierte
und dann etwa so 2 cm dick abschneiden
denn herz stelle ich jetzt doch noch mal
kurz kommt hat denn der ist schneller
als ich es bin
[Musik]
die paprika wie jetzt auch grob
geschnitten und jetzt kann ich noch die
karotten schälen und auch einfach in
scheiben schneiden
die jetzt so in fünf millimeter scheiben
[Musik]
und jetzt geht es an braten ich gebe es
erst die karotten rein weil die einfach
am längsten brauchen
ich habe wie gesagt hier möchte ich
alles schön bissfest haben und brate
jetzt etwa 12 minuten an
was kann ich noch tun ich kann jetzt
noch die zwiebel kurz schneiden in hall
bringe
[Musik]
doch der papa der papa der kauf mit doch
die blumen von dem krieg ich doch immer
nur petersilie
okay die frühlingszwiebel schneide ich
jetzt hier auch noch
hier kommt jetzt die zucchini mit rein
auch ein bisschen mit anbraten
ich glaube so langsam ein topf ist zu
klein
metz schlimm
ich wollte eigentlich so viel machen und
dann kurz meter so viel
die paprika kommt jetzt auch rein
ein deckel drauf das ist wirklich so 34
minuten lang schmoren kann ja unser land
kann ich jetzt nur warten denn alles
andere ist schon vorbereitet
die petersilie die hab ich noch die
teller übrig gelassen hat
ausschuss vermisst geführt jetzt ist man
schön deine petersilie auf den mund ich
nämlich schon ganz grün dann gehe ich
mache es gleich in den tegeler es okay
da stelle ich hier fehlt mir mein job
guck mal wie schön das macht jetzt
unsere küche viel viel schöner
[Musik]
einblicke gibt ja ja
okay das gemüse sie perfekt auch
allerdings habe ich bis hin zu großzügig
gerechnet nämlich die hälfte raus ich
schreibe ich auch etwas korrigiert auf
dem blog bzw in die app und nimmt es
einfach für morgen kann ich morgen noch
was druck machen denn für die couscous
menge erreicht auf diese menge hier
jetzt in der pfanne okay wenn es gemüse
angebrachten ist dann mit gemüsebrühe
ablöschen
kurz vorstellen lassen da die gewürze
dazugeben also minze bei salz bist ein
bisschen aufpassen je nachdem wie wird
sich schon die gemüsebrühe ist einfach
mal individuell anpassen und abschmecken
und dann könnt ihr jetzt nämlich schon
den couscous dazu geben da braucht er
nicht so langer zeit und auch keine
hochzeit
schön alles durchführen als kind habe
ich trage gerne gegessen
meine mama hat dann hat den gekommen und
habe es dann immer mit joghurt drauf
also es war so unser lieblings kinder
ist okay jetzt kann ich hier den deckel
nehme ich einfach drauf geben
die hitze auf 1 runterstellen und dann
braucht es jetzt etwa nur fünf minuten
ziehen
und ich bin fertig in der zeiträume ich
hier auf die restlichen zutaten kommen
dann nehme ich einfach kurz wurde mit
dazu porsche hat heller vom probieren
und jetzt kommt hier noch das übrige
gemüse rein also erstmal petersilie
zwiebeln die gebe ich jetzt rom mit rein
denn ich finde das passt so wirklich
perfekt weil sie rote zwiebeln einfach
sind dann die frühlingszwiebeln und
ellas gefährdete tomaten
ach schön alles durchrühren den couscous
bisschen lockern
und dann weiß ich heute drei starke
männer probieren der staat nimmt chili
mit drei starke männer eigentlich nur
einmal wissen zwei veganer bereit
hallo bafin kommt männer kommt also wie
gesagt drei balkan bringst du chili mit
ahlmann zwei veganer herauf die veganer
zu hätten was los ladies ich möchte mal
mit den vorurteilen aufräumen
pflanzen zu tun ich mache lieber bei
euch drauf 100 prozent ja ok aber bei
dir werde ich noch käse mit reingeht
über ein bisschen käse
ich darf euch leider nur so ein kleines
schildchen geben sarah muss noch
fotografiert ja aber ihr kriegt dann
danach ok klickt ihr noch mehr und das
weizen rezept das war innerhalb von 15
bis 20 minuten fertig nämlich schnell
essen und noch chili vielleicht muss ich
bei euch bisschen nachwürzen weil ich
habe es nicht so stark gewürzt damit der
käse der kompliziert bei dir noch drauf
keine flügel kam ich mache das für dich
ja murat auch chili dem starken man hier
dann lasst ihr doch nachgeben dürften
starke mann vom probiert man super
schnell ganz einfach und gesund und ich
habe alles schön bissfest gelassen weil
ihr alle noch jung sei und noch bauen
könnt
[Musik]
kann man schon öfter mal mache gern so
einfach so nach feierabend oder auch mal
zum fastenbrechen bei uns arbeitet hat
doch jeden tag urlaub aber erfolglos der
schmeckt auch dass das zutaten nicht
gekocht sind ja auf jeden fall und wie
gesagt können der gemüsesorten nehmen
die agoda habt die ihr mögt tauscht sie
gerne aus ich finde es ein cooles
grundrezept macht jeder mahl zubereiten
kann und begangen
die braucht der kamin geld das ich liebe
cous cous cous cous mit mango curry so
richtig cool ja also das rezept gibt es
in meiner ich wohl gleich noch dazu
vielleicht ist sie mit oder sie ist nur
petersilie und dann könnte es gerne
nachkochen und ein foto hochladen wir
schauen uns gerne an ok richtig bis zum
nächsten mal
man kann das übrigens auch kalt essen
als salat kann man es auch so als grill
beilage kann es auch ganz cool machen
es mag hatte recht verschieden
möglichkeiten und rico dazu ok machst du
macht's besser
ach komm ich halt zu dir
[Musik]